نتعرف اكثر ونفهم المقاربه الاسرائيليه
اذا في هذه المرحله وهناك تاكيد من قبل
نتنياهو على انغماس واستمرار في الحرب في
وقت ايضا يؤكد على استمرار
المفاوضات نعم تحياتي وصباح الخير يعني
ربما لكي نفهم ذلك بشكل اعمق يمكن ان تكون
المقاربه على لسان بلينكن الذي كان ان
هنالك يعني اجواء ايجابيه التي تت بها
اجابه حماس وفي نهايه المطاف هنالك مساحه
للمفاوضات ومساحه
ل اداره المفاوضات السريعه ان صح القول
بمفهوم كذا او كاخر فواضح جدا ان بني من
نتنياهو يحاول ان يضع الجبهه الداخليه
بمفهوم كذا او كاخر هي ذات الحمله التي
ايقاظها منذ 10 ايام ب ضد هذه الصفقه
بحمله ممنهجه يمكن القول ضد هذه الصفقه
فبالتالي هو بحاجه لكي الان يتم تصوير هذه
الصفقه بمفهوم كذا او كا اخر الى داخل
شرائح معينه في داخل اليمين شرائح معينه
في القاعده الانتخابيه الخاصه به في نهايه
المطاف اشكاليه نتنياهو كذلك مع الصفقه
الاولى كان انه دخل اليها يعني وهو صاغر
بمفهوم كهذا او كاخر هو لا يريد ان يعيد
ذات الك الان
امام جمهور ناخبيه في ذات المشهد وواضح
جدا انها غالبا ممكن ان تكون الصفقه التي
ينزل بها من على او يخرج بها من على
الرمال المتحركه في داخل القطاع ولهذا
السبب هو بحاجه ان يعني يدخل الى هذه
الصفقه بنوع من القوه بخطاب القوه وليس
بخطاب الضعف بمفهوم كذا او اخر لكن هناك
اليمين المتطرف في ائتلافه والذي يرفض اي
هدنه في هذا التوقيت وبالتالي كيف يمكن ان
يصل نتنياهو الى اي نوع من انواع وقف
اطلاق النار او صفقه مقبوله دون التصادم
مع هذا
اليمين يعني هنالك جزئين يجب ان نقراه في
داخل هذا اليمين الجزء الاول
بطبيعه الحال هو
لربما تجربه بني من نتنياهو الاخيره معهم
الاولى والاخيره معهم في عام 97
بمفهوم كذا اوكا اخر انذاك ذات اليمين
عاقب بنيامين نتنياهو على الصفقه التي قام
بها في صفقه الخليل انذاك وعقبه في صناديق
الاع الاقتراع بعد عام عام ونصف هذا الامر
في المضمار الاول ولكن من يقول ان هنالك
من يقول ان كفاءه هذا اليمين اليوم لا
ترتقي الى ذات الكفاءه التي كانت انذاك ف
بمفهوم كهذا او كاخر هو يراهن بانه على
الرغم من ذلك ربما يوجد لديه استراتيجيه
اخرى يعني بكلمات اخرى
بان ما يقوم به بينبر
الان هو في ذات السياق الاول بالمقام
الاول من ضمن المثل القائل باللغه العبريه
ان الكلب الذي ينبح لا يعض فبالتالي هو
فقط يضع الخطوط الحمراء امام بنيامين
نتنياهو ليس الا في مضمار اول ولكن وعلى
الرغم من كل ذلك كنت انا يعني انا ما كنت
ل اقلل من شان بينك فير الى هذه الدرجه
والى هذه الحد بل اكثر من ذلك كنت لاقول
ان ما يحاول ان يقوم به
هو يعني اذا كنا في ذات السياق الذي
وصفناه الكلب في نهايه المطاف هنالك حاجه
لاسكات هذا الكلب وباعتقادي انه يشير الى
داخل الضفه الغربيه كجائزه طرديه التي
ممكن ان يصمت عن طريقها بكلمات اخرى اي
نعم ان بينغ بير وسوتش في ذات السياق
يتغنون
بالضفه عفوا يتغنون بالقطاع ولكن مرادهم
في نهايه المطاف هو الضفه الغربيه ولربما
هذا كان كذلك منذ اليوم الاول اي بكلمات
اخرى
اي يعني
هنالك نوع من الادوار المتفق عليها بمفهوم
كذا او كاخ ما بين نتانياهو وبين فير
لمحاوله اطفاء نوع من الضغط امام الجانب
الامريكي على كل خاصيه الصفقه ولكن في ذات
السياق وهي نقطه مهمه جدا اعين بنفير
متجهه نحو الضفه الغربيه ليس ال طيب في ظل
دائما زياره بلينكن لاسرائيل ومنطقه بشكل
عام اين يمكن ان يكمن الخلاف في هذه
المرحله دائما بين هذا الطرف الامريكي
وبين
اسرائيل يعني في هذه الجزئيه في نهايه
المطاف انا باعتقادي كل ما
يخص التواجد الاسرائيلي في نهايه المطاف
في داخل القطاع هذا الامر الذي يعني ربما
يوجد عليه الكثير من التباين والتفاهمات
ما بين الجانبين في نهايه المطاف هنالك
مخاوف امريكيه من اعاده اي مشروع استيطاني
لداخل الضفه اللي داخل القطاع وتبيت ايه
تواجد اسرائيل العسكري في داخل القطاع هو
يؤجل ذلك وهذا الخوف هو ليس من العدم يعني
اي لان في نهايه المطاف الاستيطان هو
جائزه طرديه لجمهور بنفير وسموت والاداره
الامريكيه لا تريد باي شكل من الاشكال ان
يكون هذا الجزء من المجتمع الاسرائيلي ومن
المجتمع اليهودي في موقف قوه باي شكل من
الاشكال و وحتى لو كان ذلك على حساب دوله
فلسطينيه فانا باعتقادي اي نعم يعني
المساعي ال الجهود الراميه الى
اي يعني الدوله الفلسطينيه هي
يوجد بها نوع من الحقيقه من قبل الجانب
الامريكي
ومره اخرى و ليس حبا في بالفلسطينيين بقدر
ما هو نوع من حد
قوه الصهيونيه الدينيه بكل مفهوم الكلمه
من حيفا الكاتب المختص في الشان
الاسرائيلي ايهاب جبارين شكرا لك